we're making our own cheap Wi-Fi
pineapple hacking device
it's 3.7 volt lithium battery and a
voltage boost board to get a minimal
configuration of our very own pineapple
the 3.7 volt battery on the bottom
supplies 5 volts to the second and Ninth
GPI opens via the mt3608 DC to DC Step
Up board the voltage converter is also
connected with an external micro USB the
raspberry has two USB ports to save
battery power we'll use LEDs controlled
via the corresponding commands of the
raspberry zero OS such an indication is
convenient as the hacker will
immediately see if someone is caught
before taking the hidden device away or
if it's worth coming back later further
in a familiar shell working with a
device OS the hacker can make fine
tuning of the attack scenario and voila
now you know how hackers can build their
own device for just 15 to know more
dangers and be careful watch our big
video